Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du Linus, wenn ich dir fünfzehn Prozent von Donald Trumps Passwort sage.
Dann sage ich dir seinen IQ.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertfünfundsechzig vom dreiundzwanzigsten Oktober zweitausendundzwanzig.
Nur noch wenige Tage und dann wissen wir ja, auf ob wir alle noch einen IQ-Test brauchen. Äh.
Festzustellen, ob wir also eigentlich klug genug verhalten haben, um diesen Typen endlich loszuwerden.
Kannst du bitte, kannst du bitte mal dieses Ding einspielen, wie der, wie der das mit den mit dem Passwort und den das ist doch wirklich nicht.
Mache ich doch mal glatt.
Also damit du gehackt werden kannst, muss überhaupt erstmal der derjenige, der dich sagt, hundertsiebenundneunzig IQ Punkte haben.
Aber du hast auch mein Passwort gehackt, ohne dass ich dir fünfzehn Prozent meines Passworts gesagt habe. Wie viel Alkohol hast du denn dann?
Weiß auch nicht, wie der wie kann der auf eine so also weißt du, also tatsächlich, also ganz ehrlich.
Das ist nicht mal ein Satz.
Es ist nicht so, dass der Prozent, also der der wie viel von einem Passwort man braucht, um es zu knacken, ist auch nicht in Prozent ausdrückbar.
Also weil weil dieser Anteil ja variiert. Also es ist, es ist einfach nur und ich meine, man man sollte auch überhaupt nicht lange dadrin ruminterpretieren, weil der Typ einfach vor sich hin labert.
Ja, der labert einfach nur.
Und es ist wirklich absolut ja sehr traurig.
Aber jetzt sage ich, jetzt sage ich dir mal fünfzehn Prozent von seinem Passwort. M.
Ja, der Rest ist Mager zwanzig zwanzig aus.
Du bist so klug, du bist, du hast so einen IQ. Das ist unglaublich.
Niederländischer ähm epical Hacker hatte genauso viel IQ, also hundertsiebenundneunzig IQ.
Und der ist bei, der ist bei Twitter hingegangen, hat gesagt, ich möchte ich bin real Donald Trump, hat dann das Passwort erraten und ohne zweite Faktor-Authentisierung hatte er dann.
Zugriff,
Donald Trumps Twitter-Account. Laut eigener Aussage, ja? Das Schöne ist, die Zeitung, die das dann ähm veröffentlicht hat, andere IT-Sicherheitsexperten gefragt, ob das plausibel ist, ja?
Und und hier und gesagt, ja ist plausibel. Ja aber die haben das ja nicht aufgrund der Sicherheit beurteilt, sondern aufgrund dessen, dass es fucking Donald Trump ist, ne.
Ist es plausibel, dass dieser Vollidioten absoluter Idiot ist so?
Ja, also ich halte das schon ziemlich plausibel, dass dieser vollpfosten ein ein eine Flachzange ist, ja? Also es ist eine total oh Mann. Aber natürlich ist das ähm,
Also nur halbwitzig, weil es ja eine totale Katastrophe eigentlich ist.
Wenn äh dieser Twitter-Account äh den ja so viele Leute so ernst nehmen, ähm.
Äh einfach übernommen werden kann, ne? Von von im Prinzip jedem, der so viel Fantasie hat, wie das Donald Trump seinen eigenen,
Slogan als äh Passwort nehmen würde.
Wirklich Hardcore, also das das denen auch keiner.
Aufhalten kann. Also da müsste es ja einfach auch Leute geben, die die ganze Zeit nur damit beschäftigt sind, ihnen für sich selber zu beschützen und das misslingt auch nachhaltig.
Ich finde es erstaunlich, dass ähm.
Also man hat das ja immer wieder vor Wahlen jetzt, also erstens vor dieser US-Wahl, aber es war auch vor der äh ich ich erinnere mich vor der letzten deutschen Bundestagswahl so, dass die, dass die sozialen Netzwerke.
Im Prinzip so Initiativen hatten, Bundestagsabgeordnete anzuschreiben.
Und denen zu sagen, ey übrigens, ne, mach mal bitte zwei Faktor-Authentisierung an. Und ähm das hat.
Die haben dann zurückgegeben, irgendwie so, ja, ein Drittel der Bundestagsabgeordneten hat es nicht gemacht. Ja, und das ist äh oder oder ein Drittel hat's gemacht oder was auch immer da der äh der dieser Kontext war. Wir haben das, glaube ich, da vorm, also es war ja dann vor,
einigen Jahren auch berichtet.
Die Frage ist, warum sperren die die nicht einfach aus den Accounts aus? Und sagen, alles klar, du kommst hier einfach nicht mehr rein, wenn du nicht ähm zwei Faktoren eingeschaltet hast bis da nur dann, ne? Oder wir also,
Ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Ciao. Das sind halt also Prozesse, die müssen langsam erstmal
Sickern. Und man hat immer natürlich also aus unserer Perspektive ist es alles schon längst vorbei. Hätte vor zehn Jahren schon alles final geklärt werden müssen. Bei
Leuten kommt es irgendwie langsam so. Ich meine äh auf der anderen Seite gibt's ja auch Dinge, die bei uns dann vielleicht langsam kommen, wo andere Leute meinen, warum habt ihr das nicht schon früher äh eingesehen?
Ja
Aber ich find's ich find's wirklich, also ich meine, manchmal kannst du dich die also das sind das ist wirklich meine beiden Lieblingsnachrichten zwanzig zwanzig, wobei jetzt immer,
Deine Lieblingsnachricht zwanzig zwanzig äh schöpft ja auch insgesamt aus einem, sage ich mal, sehr kleinen Pool, ne, aber äh so die
erstens irgendwie große Fresse, irgendwas mit hundertsiebenundneunzig IQ und fünfzehn Prozent. Und drei Tage später,
kommt irgendein Holländer und mit dem ersten irgendwie in seinen Account.
Tja.
Dritter November.
Die Wahlen, ja, vielleicht sollte man zu den äh Wahlen nochmal was sagen, wie viel ähm Hoffnung man denn da überhaupt ähm.
Haben kann. Ich meine, ähm,
Also die Wahlen finden ja bereits statt. Es haben jetzt schon mehrere Millionen Leute in USA haben abgestimmt, aber am Ende werden natürlich die allermeisten versuchen, am eigentlichen Wahltag.
Stimmen abzugeben, was kein Sonntag ist, was für viele Leute ganz normaler Arbeitstag ist.
Die nicht frei kriegen. Vielleicht bei manchen Unternehmen ist es so, beim vielen wird's äh nicht so sein.
Und man sieht natürlich auch, was da allein schon systemisch verhindert wird, dass Leute überhaupt zur Wahl gehen können, insbesondere bei den Bevölkerungsgruppen, die am Ende von so einer Trump-Präsidentschaft am wenigsten haben,
erstmal dieses, man muss sich registrieren für eine Wahl, ja? Ähm als ob man nicht generell einfach mal registriert sein
äh könnte. Dann äh tausend Einschränkungen, wann man nicht wählen darf, wenn man im Knast sitzt oder da drin war oder seine Schuld noch nicht zurück bezahlt hat, alle möglichen Geschichten. Es gab eben Florida extra noch eine eine äh Grundsatzentscheidung da vom Verfassungs äh Gericht oder wie das heißt
dass das sozusagen nicht okay ist, dass Leute, die im Knast waren, nicht wählen dürfen. Nur ist das natürlich dann durch die äh nachfolgende Gesetzgebung so gedreht worden, dass die Leute jetzt äh,
Gefahr laufen, äh wenn sie irgendwelche
Rückzahlungen noch nicht vorgenommen haben, die sie vielleicht im Rahmen ihres Strafverfahrens auferlegt bekommen haben, ja, wie auch im Knast. Ja, das
dass sie dann immer noch nicht wählen dürfen. Also es wird aktiv
alles Mögliche getan, seitens der Republikaner, um Leute vom Wählen abzuhalten, weil sie eh wissen, dass sie in der Minderheit sind, auch Trump ist nur mit der Minderheit der Stimmen gewählt worden.
Und äh das Gary Mentoring, also dieses spezielle Zuschneiden von Wahlkreisen, das ist halt äh immer gesichert ist, dass sie ihre Posten behalten. Die Liste ist so unglaublich lang und sie ist so unglaublich unfassbar
dass äh dass das allein schon mal äh äh ist schon mal ein großes Problem. Und was mich aber so ein bisschen wundert, ist,
Warum redet eigentlich keiner von der elektronischen Beeinflussung.
Die dieser Wahl stattfinden könnte, ja? Das ist immer so ein bisschen so, ja, russer ist Hacking Us.
Aber äh mehr ist es irgendwie auch nicht. Und ähm ich freue mich natürlich dann als erstes immer.
Habt ihr mal geguckt, wo mitgewählt wird so, ist halt nicht immer,
Papier, sondern das sind halt schon sehr viele Computer, die da zum Einsatz kommen und sehr unterschiedliche Systeme und diese Unsicherheit dieser Systeme ist nun auch schon mehrfach auf Hacking Conventions, auch jüngst nochmal,
worden und das ist nicht irgendwie gerade so mal so ein bisschen so ein Problem, sondern richtig große, klaffende Lücken und ähm,
Aufwand, sich in solche Systeme einzuklinken und dort äh eine Wählerstimmenanpassung vorzunehmen, ist halt im Vergleich zu den ersten anderen Maßnahmen eigentlich Pipifax.
Du du beziehst dich auf das Voting Village, was da ja tatsächlich auch immer unterhalten wird auf der äh Security-Konferenz Defcon,
wo die im Prinzip ja auf dem Kongress wär's eine quasi eine eigene
Ecke haben, wo die die ganzen Wahlcomputer hinstellen und die Dinger in einen nach dem anderen aufmachen, ja? Und da ist im Prinzip so ungefähr der Wettkampf ist nur noch, wie viele du aufmachst, nicht, dass du überhaupt einen aufmachst, ne? Und äh das ist es ist alles ganz.
Ja, es ist so wie Zauber Zauberwürfel äh äh Competition. Ja, also alle kriegen den gelöst. Ist die nur noch die Frage, ob sie in den sechs Sekunden gelöst bekommst oder in in fünf Komma neun.
Um Zauberwürfel zu lösen. Tim brauchst du hundertsiebenundneunzig IQ und du musst auf jeden Fall schon mal fünfzehn Prozent müssen richtig sein. Sonst weiß ja klar, du wenn der ganz durcheinander ist, ne, dann weißt du ja gar nicht, ob Gelb oben oder unten ist.
Wie schnell kannst du den Zauberwürfel lösen? Kannst du überhaupt einen Zauberwürfel lösen?
Ich habe keinen, um's auszuprobieren. Ich weiß, dass es äh ich ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass ich dadrin besonders gut bin.
Ich war da mal ganz gut drin, aber na ja.
Ich weiß. Deswegen habe ich den ja auch weggenommen.
Zur Weltmeisterschaft habe ich's auch nicht gebracht. Da kannst du, da kannst du irgendwie mit so mageren siebenunddreißig Sekunden kannst du da nicht kommen.
Äh ja, stattdessen, also aber,
Also ich meine, die der Gesamtzustand dieser Demokratie in den USA ist, ist sowieso wirklich haarsträubend, ne? Wenn man sich überlegt, dass das die groß macht, ist die im Prinzip, ne, liberale Demokratie,
ähm in die in die Welt exportiert hat, ja, wen nicht wenige Länder haben
auch den USA eine Demokratie zu verdanken. Einige natürlich auch 'ne Diktatur. Das
kommt halt immer darauf an, was äh die wirtschaftlichen Interessen der USA sind, aber einige Länder, wie zum Beispiel die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, haben relativ eindeutig den USA eine halbwegs funktionierende Demokratie zu verdanken
ja? Und ähm es ist haarsträubend, wenn man sich überlegt,
Erstens, also mit den Wahlcomputern. Jo, dann diese ganze Geschichte mit den Wahlpersonen, die sie da absenden, ja, also auch irgendwie ein ein Urzeits äh,
ein Urzeitrelikt, ja, als man noch kein, kein Internet hatte und und mit Postkutschen irgendwie die die.
Wahlen irgendwie klären musste, um halt und damit halt nur die Integrität der Wahl sichern konnte, dass man halt eine Person hinschickt und sagt, alles klar, die wird das jetzt machen.
Ähm das Gerry Mendering, was du schon angesprochen hast, die also das das gezielt und es geht da immer nur um darum äh im Prinzip die Anzahl wählender schwarzer, niedrig zu halten,
ähm.
All diese Phänomene, auch aus solche skurrilen Situationen, wie man jetzt mit der ähm mit der mit den Berufungen zum Supreme Court sieht, ja, wo also diese Lebenszeitberufungen in dieses Gericht,
Ja zur zur absoluten, zum absoluten Krieg zwischen den beiden Parteien führen. Das ist alles so kaputt, ja, dass man sich ernsthaft fragen möchte, wie dieses Land hier noch.
Ich meine, mit dem Präsidenten sowieso nicht und mit vielen anderen Dingen, die sie tun auch nicht, aber wie das überhaupt noch als das als die Modelldemokratie irgendwie sich hier,
hinhalten soll, wo die so damit beschäftigt sind, diese Demokratie wirklich gezielt kaputt zu machen und alle wissen's, ja?
Ist wirklich fasziniert. Ja, stattdessen machen sich irgendwelche Gedanken und sagen, ja, die Russen äh hacken die, äh US-Regierungsziele, ja, als würden sie das sonst nicht machen. Und dann äh finde ich's ja doch sehr spannend.
Es gab ja jetzt zwei Leaks im weitesten Sinne. Einmal.
Eine Geschichte der New York Post, wo angeblich der Sohn von.
Joe Biden, ein ähm ein ein Laptop in der Reparatur abgegeben hat und nicht mehr abgeholt hat.
Welchem Grund auch immer, ja? Und dieses Laptop ist irgendwie in den Händen von Juliani gelandet,
die ehemaligen New Yorker Bürgermeister und jetzt persönlichen Anwalt von Donald Trump. Der einzige, wo ich mich frage, ob der nicht vielleicht noch mehr einen Knall hat als Donald Trump und.
Der hat das irgendwie äh und die New York Post hat dann veröffentlicht, dass dort E-Mails drin sind, wo im Prinzip jemand, äh der aus dem Ausland ist, quasi den.
Sohn von Joe Biden um einen Termin mit Joe Biden bitte zu der Zeit wo Joe Biden,
Vizepräsident ist und sich nachher dafür bedankt. Jetzt gibt's aber tausende Zweifel daran, dass dieses Material überhaupt echt ist.
Weil irgendwie die Seriennummer an dem Laptop äh von der die Seriennummer von der Festplatte deutet auf ein anderes Jahr hin als da irgendwie angegeben ist. Und also es gibt irgendwie eine Reihe an an Unstimmigkeiten.
Und dann hast du noch diese, dann hast du erstmal eine Debatte darüber, dass Twitter den Link dazu unterdrückt, was natürlich auch irgendwie nicht so geil ist, aber äh und letztendlich jetzt zu einem äh Effekt dann geführt hat,
und gleichzeitig versucht dieser taucht von dem Juliani ein Video auf, wo der im ersten Moment, wo er mit einer Frau alleine ist, äh sich irgendwie in die Hose greift,
Also das ist doch wirklich ich will hier auch ein bisschen noch was mit mit Anstand haben.
Also du hast wirklich Forderungen unglaublich.
Meine ist natürlich wieder ein interessanter Streisand äh Effekt, ne, wenn äh äh Twitter auf einmal so einen Bericht sperrt, dann steigt natürlich automatisch das Interesse an diesem Bericht. Ein generelles Problem.
Ja, Twitter hat vor allem, also was Twitter gemacht hat, die haben sich da, die haben sich mal wieder, man fragt sich auch ernsthaft, wird dieser Twitter reagiert
regelmäßig in in in vielen Situationen vollkommen dämlich. Fragst dich, also sie haben ja dann verhindert,
dass man ähm diesen Link überhaupt twittert. Wenn du den eingibst, dann,
konntest du, konntest du nicht twittern. Mit anderen Worten alle Märkten sofort, okay, hier findet eine äh Gegenmaßnahme gegen diese Verbreitung statt
ja? Facebook hat, glaube ich, das eher so gemacht, dass sie gesagt haben, alles klar, was wer das verbreitet, das wird einfach runtergegradet, das zeigen wir einfach nicht so viel,
ja? Und bremsen damit einfach diese Verbreitung äh subtil aus. Was natürlich eine elegantere Methode ist, ne?
Beide aber eben höchst fragwürdig.
Immerhin probieren sie was. Also ich meine, das muss man ihnen auch mal zugute halten. Äh ich glaube, sie haben schon äh seit längerer Zeit ein sehr schlechtes Gewissen. Im Gegensatz zu Facebook.
Ja, na ja. Okay, du hattest noch, wir haben eine sehr schöne Grafik gefunden, die wir hier mal featuren wollten.
Ja, ja, also es gibt da eine Person, die heißt äh Abby Richards, die weit ich weiß, äh Klimaforscherin ist und da irgendwie unterwegs ist, also Wissenschaftlerin, die irgendwie Bescheid weiß und unter anderem auch ein TikTok
und äh Instagram äh und Twitter-Account unterhält.
Und die hat sich auf eine ganz interessante Art und Weise mal mit Verschwörungstheorien auseinandergesetzt, indem sie ein,
aufgemacht hat. Und das ist so 'n auf 'n Kopf gestellte Pyramide, die Verschwörungstheorien
in äh eine von fünf Kategorien einteilt,
fünf, ja? Das äh steckt da auch schon wieder so eine Zahl dahinter. Wusstest du, dass fünf äh Quersumme von dreiundzwanzig ist?
Ja, natürlich. Und das ist kein Zufall. Das kannst du mir nicht erzählen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist einfach alles von langer Hand geplant. Na ja, auf jeden Fall äh war ihre Kategorisierung ganz interessant. Und zwar ähm.
Ist äh im unteren Teil äh der Pyramide sozusagen der Bereich, wo es losgeht, ja, so quasi so der Einstiegsbereich für Verschwörungstheorien. Und sie nennt diesen Bereich things,
Und es handelt sich hier sozusagen um Dinge, ähm ja, die gar nicht so sehr Verschwörungstheorien sind, sondern das sind halt einfach so Sachen, die so, ja, finden statt so. Äh Massenüberwachung durch die NSA.
Ja, wissen wir, ja. Äh die Tabakindustrie hat jahrelang äh über die Folgen von rauchen auf auf Krebs äh gelogen. Mhm, ja genau, hat äh stattgefunden,
Da sind auch noch so ein paar andere, die ich gar nicht so genau kenne, aber du äh kennst da was dadrüber, hier so.
Ja, so Maßnahmen des FBI eben gegen ähm gegen politische Bürger, bürgerliche Bewegungen und so, ne, also wo,
Ja, dass das FBI gegen politische Willensbildung vorgegangen ist, ne? Also alles da ist so ein typisches US-Ding, ne. So eine so eine wahnsinnige Irre
Grundrechtsverletzung und Verschwörung ja ja ist ganz normal da, ja.
Genau und und da würde ich dann auch mal so äh explizit mal auch sagen, ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt so Verschwörungstheorien dieser Art,
auch in unserer Hacker-Community,
nicht sich größer Beliebtheit erfreut hätten in den letzten zehn, zwanzig, dreißig Jahren. Also so mit so Verschwörungstheorien rumzuspielen und mit diesen alternativen Realitäten.
Und dieses ich weiß was, was ihr nicht wisst äh äh Ding, das macht ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht auch Spaß, beziehungsweise es ist natürlich auch ein
eine eine Perspektive, die man so einnehmen kann, so dieses, ja, ich glaube auch nicht alles, was in der Zeitung steht. Und das eher, sagen wir mal, aus so einer,
Grundhaltung eines eines kritischen Denkens. Was nicht heißt, ich glaube überhaupt nix mehr, was in der Zeitung steht, sondern ich mache mir zumindest erstmal darüber Gedanken, was äh.
Vor allem, was was auch nicht heißt, ich glaube nicht, was in der Zeitung steht. Deswegen glaube ich jetzt einfach mal, wahllos irgendetwas anderes, ja? Also
das ist halt nicht kritisches,
das muss man irgendwie auch glaube ich diesen diesen Hill-Männern und und wie die da diese ganzen Vögel heißen, nochmal erklären, ne? Wenn die sagen, glaubt nicht, glaubt nicht, was in den Medien steht, glaubt, was im Internet steht, das ist keine saubere Alternative, ne.
Unser Freund äh Hildmann äh steht in diesen Charts, das werden wir gleich sehen. Auf jeden Fall äh trennt jetzt sozusagen dieser erste Bereich von Things the Action in happend, ist jetzt durch,
eine Linie äh vom zweiten Teil getrennt, das ist die sogenannte Line. Also die Spekulationsgrenze,
Und äh dieser Bereich ist mit we have Questions umschrieben und da kommen dann so Sachen rein wie Ufos, Rosswall,
Area wurde JFK äh ermordet und so.
Naja, er wurde ermordet, ne? Da da ist.
Ja von also von wem wurde er, von wem wurde er ermordet? Ja, wie stark Prinzess Diana äh irgendwie,
hat sich vielleicht nicht selber umgebracht und so. Ja genau, we have questions so, also es ist so, ja, könnte so sein, könnte so sein, die Erkenntnislage.
Ist aber eher so, ja, nee, gibt eigentlich eher keine Ufos und äh Area Fifty Wein beschäftigt sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt den ganzen Tag mit dem Sitzhirn von äh Aliens, so, aber na ja, Gott, äh gut, man kann ja mal
da kann man ja auch mal lustig drüber nachdenken. Ähm
damit ist auch niemanden irgendwie groß äh geschadet, außer dass das Hirn langsam anfängt zu rosten. Dann gibt's äh die nächste Grenze, die überschritten wird, die mit Living Reality bezeichnet ist
Also hier verlässt man dann so so sie verlassen den realistischen Sektor.
Da sind so schöne Sachen drin wie Elvis lebt noch, äh Greta-Wünbeck ist eine Zeitreisende,
Und das Loch Nessmonster und die sind markiert als,
eindeutig falsch, aber größtenteils harmlos, ne? Also äh ob jetzt Alien Stonehenge gebaut haben oder, und, und ausgetauscht wurde, ist relativ unerheblich, ne? Und dann kommt die die.
Kornkreise auch.
Interessanten Grenzen, also du weigerst dich.
Verweigert sich der Wissenschaft und da beginnt es mit, gefährlich für dich selbst und andere.
Mhm. Und da kommt dann halt Global Warming. Finnland, das ist ein Exist, das kannte ich übrigens noch gar nicht. Ist das quasi internationale Version von Bielefeld?
Das war mir auch nicht bekannt. Finnland jetzt, das gibt's doch gar nicht.
Das ist doch wirklich bitte dich.
Genau, aber dann halt auch so die ganz aktuellen Sachen so mit fünf G äh ist irgendwie gefährlich und die Strahlen und äh,
halt natürlich dann auch diese ganze Bewegung gegen äh gegen Impfstoffe und äh
der saß Virus wurde in einem Labor in China gemacht und äh halt auch dann dieser ganze Snakekram mit so, ja, hier nimmt dies, das macht dich schon gesund, trink äh trink Bleiche. Also,
wo wirklich mit diesem Glauben an diese Verschwörungstheorie eine akute Bedrohung, entweder von dir selber oder eben von anderen besteht und wo es dann einfach auch nicht mehr lustig ist. Wobei ich mir jetzt noch nicht so ganz so sicher bin, was das mit Findern zu tun hat.
Fällt mir übrigens auf, äh fällt mir was ein, ich war letzte Woche, glaube ich, bei hm bei im ARD Hauptstadtstudio oder war das diese Woche, ich weiß es nicht. Ähm.
Nee, letzte Woche. Letzte Woche. Diese Woche auch, aber letzte Woche äh zu einem äh ARD Social zu fünf G.
Und äh äh wo ich ähm da da hat nämlich jetzt die Bundesregierung, hat ja jetzt äh entschieden,
ähm irgendwie diese Auflagen dazu machen, ne, wo man
ob man die jetzt Huawei reinlässt oder nicht. Und dazu äh habe ich dann endlich mal die Gelegenheit bekommen, so in zwanzig, dreißig Minuten zu sprechen, alles ein paar Themen, die ich hier auch im Blogbuch eigentlich schon behandelt habe, aber ich,
verlinkt das trotzdem mal, weil sowohl zu Beginn,
als auch zum Ende hin dann aus den Zuschauerfragen immer so ja und könnten wir vielleicht nochmal das klären mit dem 5G und Corona?
Die natürlich äh also da waren äh Leute, die das die einfach noch mal die Gelegenheit geben wollten, dass das äh.
Aber aber wer meint, dass der dass man damit jetzt schon den Höhepunkt erreicht hätte, ja, mit äh äh Impf,
Verweigerung, Chemtrails und 5G. Da gibt es noch eine Linie, Tim.
Genau, dann kommt nämlich die antisemitische äh der antisemitische äh also wurde dann auch irgendwo verloren bist und wo es vor allem äh sich dann im zunehmenden Maße einfach gegen.
Die äh Juden gegen äh,
Die jüdische Vergangenheit, die gegen Israel und äh alles andere, was man mit Antisemitismus noch verbinden möchte und muss äh,
und dann geht's dann halt richtig los mit irgendwie Nazis, äh Leben auf dem Mond, die Erde ist hohl äh,
natürlich dann George Soros steckt hinter allem, Q-Annoren natürlich jetzt als äh das neue Master-Piece äh.
Bill Gates will dich chippen.
Genau.
Weisen von Zion. Oh herrje.
Holocaust hat nicht stattgefunden.
New World Order. Also, das so, das ist einfach, was ich sehr interessant fand an dieser Grafik ist einfach diese diese dass diese Eskalation,
im Glauben von Wahnsinn, die sich sehr schön ablesen lässt. Das ist einfach anfängt, mit
mit Zweifel an der Welt so, weil der ist auch berechtigt. Und nicht alles, was so gemeinhin von irgendjemand behauptet wird, stimmt so. Aber dann geht's halt schnell in Sachen rein mit ha, was wäre wenn und äh jetzt könnte ich mir auch noch total absurde Sachen vorstellen und dann werden die absurden Sachen so krass, dass einfach
sie eigentlich mit einer normalen Wahrnehmung der Realität nicht mit zu verbinden ist, weil ich meine, Elvis ist einfach tot. Ja, so.
Meinst du.
Ja und es gab die Beatles. So. Ja und dann äh dann aber eben schnell und dann dann kommt ja dann sozusagen ist ja eine normale Reaktion von den Leuten mit hundertsiebenundneunzig IQ.
Schon mal fünfzehn Prozent deines Passworts wissen. Äh ist halt so, ja wieso, wir haben aber Wissenschaft und wir haben quasi ein ein etabliertes System, an dem wir quasi Wahrheit, Belegbarkeit auch konkret messen können,
Und dann
muss, aber auch da äh alles abgelegt werden, weil es ja nicht einfach jetzt hier mit mit Wissenschaft und klar belegbaren Fakten kommen,
dann dann kann ich ja nicht mehr weiter glauben, was was mein absurdes,
Weltbild befördert, was ich eigentlich mir jetzt zulege, um eine dicke Haut zu bekommen, weil ich einfach den Rest nicht mehr verstehe oder von der Gesellschaft mich alleingelassen fühle und mich jetzt einfach auch stark fühlen möchte. Und dann bist du halt einfach in diesem, ja, Wissenschaft äh myS,
Mir doch egal, ich glaube jetzt einfach mal jeden Scheiß und dann wirst du halt radikalisiert, weil du an an der Stelle dann einfach wunderbar abgeholt wirst. Also in dem Moment, wo du nicht mehr an, an, an die Wirkung der Medizin glaubst.
Dann bist du einfach auch schon sehr nah dran an Leuten, die dann einfach den puren Menschenhass auffahren, der sich dann halt einfach in antisemitischen Parolen und vielen anderen äh Dingen äußert und dann dann bist du einfach,
Opfer. Und das haben wir sehr schön gesehen bei diesen Anti-Corona-Demos. Wo einfach verstrahlte Heilpraktiker-Hippies rumlaufen.
Irgendwie in die Kamera äh berichten mit Nazis, ich sehe keine Nazis. Und in dem Moment läuft irgendwie einer mit White Power Tattoo irgendwie Skinhead Look und irgendwie äh anderen äh.
Nicht nur nicht nur in dem Moment, nicht nur in dem Moment läuft er da lang.
Aber aber wirklich in dem Moment, wo sie sagt, so Nazis, ich sehe hier keine Nazis, läuft wirklich ein Nazi durch die Kamera, zehn Zentimeter hinter ihr. Und das ist einfach so absurd, ja? Und das ist einfach ein Problem,
Dass Leute sich da einfach so äh,
Wegradikalisieren lassen und irgendwann einfach nur noch Opfer äh sind und dann glauben müssen, die Erde wäre hohl oder äh die demokratischen Partei in USA betreiben Pädophilen Ring in,
Keller an einer Pizzaauslieferungsbude.
So, deswegen deswegen behandeln wir heute in dieser Sendung, ja, genug Krankenschweiß, der tatsächlich passiert ist.
Aber vorher möchte ich noch eine kurze äh kurzes Public Service Announcement machen.
Und zwar wird ja an äh Stelle des,
Congress im Dezember vom siebenundzwanzigsten bis dreißigsten. Die Remote KOS Experience stattfinden, also eine äh wie fast alle Veranstaltungen leider remote stattfindende.
Zusammenkunft, die so gut es geht,
ähm uns in dieser Zeit helfen soll, uns mit ein bisschen Content versehen soll und mit ein bisschen fern äh bildlicher Zusammenkunft. Da wurde jetzt der Call for Assembles ähm veröffentlicht.
Und das wird also so sein, dass ein zentraler Datenknoten bereitgestellt wird
wo sich die ganzen dezentralen Projekte, Vorträge, Workshops, Essen und so weiter,
miteinander verknüpfen können, sodass es dann im Prinzip, ne, du hast ein bisschen oft, was weiß ich, der RC drei Seite und kannst dann zu den unterschiedlichen gehen und wie die sich dort repräsentieren, gibt's natürlich,
viele unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten.
Und äh deswegen ist jetzt der Käufer schon raus, um damit den Assembles zu arbeiten. Insbesondere, ne, was natürlich nahe liegt für so ein ist, zum Beispiel, ein,
Chaos Studio zu unterhalten, Kaostudio, also eine äh im Prinzip eine Aufzeichnungsbühne, wo dann vielleicht äh Speakerinnen ihre Vorträge live vor einem Kleinstpublikum,
halten können oder eben auch äh Voraufzeichnen können.
Und wenn man jetzt schon sich die Mühe macht, ein eigenes Studio zu bauen, bietet sich natürlich auch an,
Eine Communitybühne darauf zu haben, also Communityprogramm äh selber anzubieten. Ich weiß von vielen äh Orten, die das jetzt schon äh fleißig planen und wenn auch ihr darauf Bock habt, dann ist der,
im
bei uns in den verlinkt. Besonders lustig fand ich übrigens die Telekommunisten haben jetzt schon mal angefangen ihr Sambli zu bauen,
Und zwar machen die so ein äh Muh. Weißt du, kennst du den Mut, MOO?
Multi äh.
Was ist das immer? Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wofür mu steht. Äh Online-Community. Mal gucken.
Also.
Also Text Adventure. Abcheck orientiert matt und matt ist ein.
Also so ein Multi User.
Also ich denke man muss schon oft gesagt, man muss dann eben.
Schauen, äh wie gut man mit den mit den Fesseln noch tanzen kann und deswegen finde ich's äh schön, wenn da ähm,
sich Dinge ergeben. Kommen wir endlich zu Krankenschweiz, der tatsächlich passiert ist.
Ja. Vermutlich vor, also so genau weiß man das ja auch nicht, ne.
Doch relativ wahrscheinlich ist es passiert.
Weiß man? Was denn?
Das jetzt schon, also äh und zwar.
Haben wir hier ja schon seit vielen Jahren darüber berichtet, dass es diese ursprünglich äh auch in Deutschland basierte,
Staatstrojanerschmiede.
Namens Gamma Finnischer gibt, so das Produkt heißt Finn Fischer, der äh Firmenname variiert ähm.
Ursprünglich war das irgendwie Gamma, äh wenn ich das richtig erinnere, dann kam, gab's aber alle möglichen Finn Fischer und Finn hasse nicht gesehen, GmbHs und überall und.
Du dich versiehst, gibt's auf einmal viele Unternehmen auf dem Planeten, die aber am Ende mh dann doch eine Software verkaufen.
Und zwar die gleiche. Und ähm
da haben Torsten und ich ja letztes Jahr ein ähm also Torsten Schröder und ich eine Analyse dann angefertigt, die sehr viele Finn Fischer zugeschriebene,
ähm ähm Samples für Android untersucht hat und da drin die ähm.
Ähnlichkeiten und äh Weiterentwicklungen aufgezeichnet. Das heißt, wir haben ähm quasi,
nachgezeichnet, wie diese Software
sich über die Jahre verändert hat von den Veröffentlichen die wir dafür hatten. Das haben wir nicht haben wir nicht einfach aus Spaß gemacht, sondern das haben wir mit den konkreten Untersuchungsauftrag oder mit einer Untersuchungsbitte gemacht, nämlich der Untersuchungsbitte von der GFF-Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte
die uns im Prinzip ein Sample gegeben haben, eine äh ähm
Ja, also eine eine Schadsoftware und gesagt haben, hier könnt ihr Aussage dazu treffen.
Wann die hergestellt wurde und was das ist. Und diese Aussage haben wir eben getroffen durch.
Den Vergleich mit anderen bekanntermaßen Finn Fischer zugeordneten Schadsoftware Samples und dann äh quasi durch die dort verwendeten Librarys ähm quasi den frühesten Herstellungszeitpunkt.
Ähm identifiziert. So, warum war das relevant? Weil das Sample, was die ähm.
GFF uns da äh zur Verfügung gestellt hat.
In der Türkei gegen Oppositionelle eingesetzt wurde, gegen politische Oppositionelle und zwar äh ich glaube zwanzig siebzehn oder sowas. Oder im Moment der Einsatz bin ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so sicher. Ähm.
Also es wurde in der Türkei gegen die gegen Oppositionelle eingesetzt. So, jetzt gibt es in Deutschland ein Gesetz, das dieses,
Softwareprodukt Finn Fischer und andere, also andere dieser Art Dual-Use Güter.
Ähm Exportrestriktionen unter äh unterzieht mit anderen Worten, du kannst das nicht einfach,
ähm in ein ähm in ein anderes Land,
exportieren. Und ich habe gerade nochmal kurz geschaut, genau zwanzig siebzehn wurde das in der Türkei eingesetzt und diese Exportrestriktion galten ab dem achtzehnten Juli zwanzig fünfzehn, ne? Und jetzt musste quasi,
nachgewiesen werden oder geprüft werden, ob es einen Hinweis gibt, dass dieses Sample, was zwanzig siebzehn eingesetzt wurde in der Türkei, nach zwanzig fünfzehn,
hergestellt wurde. Und da hat äh haben wir mehrere Hinweise gefunden und auch andere äh Forscher haben ebenfalls diese ähm.
Diese und andere Hinweise gefunden. Und dieser ganze technische,
Beweis in Anführungszeichen wurde dann für eine Anzeige genutzt für eine Strafanzeige von äh Reporter ohne Grenzen, Netzpolitik, ORGF,
und dem,
ECHR. Strafanzeige gemacht und ähm haben da unter anderem den ähm,
Bericht, den wir dann auch formuliert haben, damit beigefügt. So, bei dem Zollkriminalamt, das zur Kriminalamt muss nämlich solche,
dann eben ist dafür zuständig das zu überprüfen. Und das darüber haben Torsten zusammen mit Ulf Buhrmeier von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte auch bei dem Kongress noch einen Vortrag gehalten.
Und jetzt ist erstmal lange Zeit nichts passiert. Bis jetzt vor einigen Tagen die sehr überraschende Nachricht ähm.
Uns ereilte, nämlich am fünfzehnten Oktober wurde die, glaube ich, veröffentlicht, dass wegen des Verdachts gegen den wegen des Verdachts.
Nach Verstoß gegen das Außenwirtschaftsgesetz.
Fünfzehn Wohn- und Geschäftsräume im In- und Ausland durchsucht wurden. Also fünfzehn äh also insgesamt fünfzehn Objekte in verschiedenen Ländern,
ähm wir wurden durchsucht, weil sich dieser Verdacht,
eben zu dieser Strafanzeige geführt hat, halt auch tatsächlich erhärtet hat. Ähm ich habe dann mal irgendwie zu,
mit Ulf stehe ich natürlich in Kontakt. Ähm habe dann irgendwie gesagt, hör mal, Ulf, ähm erscheint mir reichlich spät, bis dahin hat haben diese Täter doch längst aufgeräumt, ne. Die wissen ja, seit vielen Monaten von den Ermittlungen,
und äh Ulf äh hat ja Ahnung von äh Strafrecht und so. Tja, Richter sagte dann so, na ja, ähm.
Das heißt, äh klar ist das spät, aber das heißt andererseits, dass der Verdacht so ausreichend erhärtet ist,
dass die äh in verschiedene fünfzehn Objekte durchsuchen, da allen möglichen Kram beschlagnahmen äh und das auch noch auf international machen in vielen verschiedenen Ländern. Insofern.
Könnte das sein, dass äh sich dieser Verdacht jetzt tatsächlich erhärtet und es gibt im Prinzip nur ähm,
Also, ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, ich habe keinen Zweifel daran, dass diese Software von denen stammt. Ähm.
Die haben allerdings, das ist ja auch genau der Punkt, viele unterschiedliche Firmen,
und mit Sicherheit gibt es jetzt keinen Vertrag zwischen sagen wir mal der Filmfischer Deutschland GmbH so ungefähr mit,
Erdogan.
Organisation zur zu Bekämpfung politischer Organisation, ne? Äh das, wo die sagen, alles klar, wir liefern euch einen Staatstrojaner, sondern es gibt natürlich, sowas geht über Reseller und über unterschiedliche ähm
Unternehmen und dann verkaufst, exportierst du halt in das eine Land und das Land exportiert woanders hin, ne? Tatsächlich sind aber natürlich diese,
Maßnahmen zur Umgehung dieser Exportkontrollen genauso verboten.
Wie der direkte Export. Mit anderen Worten, die werden sich jetzt äh im Zweifelsfall verantworten müssen. Ähm.
Dahingehend.
Dieses Schlupfloch, was sie genutzt haben, legal ist. Und wenn das Schlupfloch, was sie genutzt haben, legal ist, dann sind's zwar keine Straftäter, äh haben aber trotzdem was sehr Schlechtes getan und äh das Gesetz muss dann irgendwie angepasst werden.
Oder es wird ihnen eben tatsächlich eine eine willliche und bösartige äh Umgehung der Exportrestriktion nachgewiesen und dann werden sie eventuell auch dafür bestraft werden. Ähm interessant ist, dass.
Die also dieses Firmengeflecht, was die sich da gebaut haben, ne, gibt's irgendwie im Handelsregister von Malaysia hat Stefan, das war einer der Geschäftsleute hinter Finn Fischer, äh zwanzig fünfzehn eine ein Unternehmen gegründet,
und der ist aber dann zwanzig sechzehn äh verstorben. Äh und,
die Anteile gehören jetzt laut Handelsregister, zu einem Viertel, einem Entwickler und den Rest verwaltet ein Anwalt aus München, dessen Kanzlei die gleiche Postadresse hat wie Finn Fischer.
In München. Also das sind halt.
Weißt du, das sind wirklich, ich meine, keine Ahnung, ne, wenn du, wenn du das Hecken von Menschen ähm zu deinem,
zu deiner Dienstleistung machst und das irgendwie für ähm ne Barain, Ägypten, Türkei und derartige äh Demokratiemassen, ne.
Ja, dann äh.
Ist es vielleicht doch ganz gut, wenn wir Gesetze haben, die solchen Leuten ähm einen einen Strich durch die Rechnung machen. Ich finde, da ist natürlich, kann sich hin,
nicht zu äh man darf sich hier nicht zu früh freuen. Ich gehe davon aus, wir wissen aus dem ersten Hack von Finn Fischer, den damals ja der ähm
durchgeführt hat und viele Daten veröffentlicht hat, dass die sehr gerne mit Verschlüsselung arbeiten. Äh und insofern ist es gut möglich, dass ähm.
Die Ergebnisse, die dort vorgetragen werden, äh oder die dort rausgetragen werden, sehr dürftig sind. Wir haben aber gleichzeitig natürlich die Situation, das habe ich auch damals bei unserer Veröffentlichung immer gesagt, wir haben ja die Tools
und die Analysen, die wir durchgeführt haben, alle veröffentlicht auf Gitter und haben dann gesagt, na, der einfachste Weg.
Herauszufinden, ob das Fin Fischer ist. Nehmt den Finn Fischer, den das BKA.
Und das äh zum Beispiel jetzt bin die Berliner Polizei bei Finn Fischer selber kaufen
macht unsere Analysen, wir helfen euch auch gerne dabei. Ihr könnt euch uns auch gerne einfach die Samples geben. Wir machen das vor für euch und dann habt ihr eh den den Nachweis, ne? Das ist das gleiche Produkt,
in unterschiedlichen äh Ländern verkauft wird. Ähm ich bin also mal sehr äh gespannt.
Ob das am Ende ein, ob hier am Ende die Guten siegen, ja?
Aber man muss natürlich auch sagen, weißt du, wie viele Jahre Arbeit das jetzt ist von,
ganz, ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Leuten, die die diesen Staatstrojaner jagen und die seit jeher,
äh da ein Auge drauf haben. Ich weiß das, ich ich gucke mir Finn Fischer an, seit dem ersten Staatstrojaner Heck des CCC, der war, glaube ich, zweitausendelf, ne? Also seit jetzt neun Jahren,
gucken wir da gucken wir uns das an und da muss man sagen da gibt's Leute immer wieder betroffene und Zielpersonen die das die das entdeckt haben und irgendwie der Forschungsgemeinschaft zur Verfügung gestellt haben damit wir den Anschluss nicht verlieren diese Leute zu durchsuchen. Es gibt,
Den ein oder anderen Whistleblower in, im Unternehmen, der mal den ein oder andere Information durchgestochen hat. Das ist auch natürlich,
sehr gut, wenn Leute so etwas machen. Dann gibt's Claudio Guardiri, der seit vielen Jahren äh unterschiedliche Staatstrojaner äh sucht,
Und jetzt äh bei Amnesty im Security Lab mitarbeitet, die jetzt auch,
Erst kürzlich wieder, ich hatte das, glaube ich, letzte oder vorletzte Sendung erwähnt, in Ägypten den Einsatz nachgewiesen haben,
Amnesty Security Lab, ja äh seit einigen Jahren da sehr aktiv. Wir haben Andre Meister, der da auch immer auf auf Netzpolitik org drüber ähm.
Schreibt, wir haben Fischer, wir haben das Citizen Lab, diese Forschungsgruppe aus Toronto, die dort an der Universität sind, unter Ronald Dibert, wir haben ESET,
wir haben sogar Microsoft und so, die irgendwie teilweise schon ihre Ergebnisse in der,
Erforschung dieser Schadsoftware äh veröffentlicht haben.
Und dann dauert es immer noch so lange und da muss irgendwie, ne, diese muss eine Spenden finanzierte äh.
NGO sich mit eins, zwei, drei
anderen zu vier anderen zusammentun, um irgendwie eine Strafanzeige zu formulieren. Torsten und ich müssen paar Monate Scheiß-Software-Samples analysieren,
Wie gesagt, die andere Forscher ja auch Excess Now und so weiter. Und das alles anschleppen und dann kannst du irgendwann einmal hoffen,
dann viele Jahre später das Zeugkriminalamt da wenigstens mal eine Durchsuchung macht und eine eine Verurteilung steht ja dann immer noch weit in,
in ferner Zukunft. Und währenddessen macht hier die Bundesregierung oder also die Strafverfolgungsbehörden zumindest und das äh äh Innenministerium,
mit diesen Leuten Geschäfte und baut das auch noch aus, womit wir beim nächsten Thema wären, denn es gibt jetzt einen Kabinettsbeschluss.
Indem die Staatstrojaner nicht nur für Strafverfolgungsbehörden eingesetzt werden sollen, sondern eben auch für Geheimdienste,
Ja? Mit der Begründung, kann ja nicht sein, dass die Polizei das darf, aber die Geheimdienste nicht.
Ähm ebenfalls, äh das berichte ich hier aber gar nicht, hat ja irgendwie die ähm.
Gab's wieder diesen BSi Lagebericht der IT-Sicherheit in Deutschland, wo sie dann sagen, es gibt hunderttausend Viren jeden Tag, ja und
äh unverändert kritisch äh alles im Cyber, ja. Berichte ich ja gar nicht mehr, ne? Und dann einen Tag später kommt der Kabinettsbeschluss ähm,
jo, alles klar, jetzt bekommen alle neunzehn Geheimdienste. Das sind sechzehn Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz, ein Bundesamt,
Für Verfassungsschutz der BND und der militärische Abschirmdienst alle kriegen jetzt die die Berechtigung zum Einsatz von Staatstrojanern.
Ähm und Internetanbieter werden jetzt verpflichtet, bei der Installation dieser Schadsoftware zu helfen.
Relativ starkes Stück. Erstens mal, warum ist das kritisch, wenn Geheimdienst das machen? Geheimdienste legen de facto, müssen die für ihr Tun keine Rechenschaft ablegen. Die Geheimdienste, insbesondere hier Verfassungsschutz und so,
sind diejenigen, die die Terror- und Nazistrukturen in Deutschland aufgebaut haben und äh am Leben halten, ja, das dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Wenn immer irgendwo eine Nazigruppe hochgeht, äh äh geht irgendwie ähm in irgendein Landesamt und im Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, Verfassungsschutz der Schredder an, ja? Was haben wir letztens noch äh herausgefunden,
die finden ja alles raus. Hier der der Personenschützer von wie heißt nochmal der Chef des,
BFV, Haldewang oder was?
Ähm und dessen Personenschützer ist. Äh.
Da haben wir auf jeden Fall hatte der der der Personenschützer von dem Chef des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz.
Thomas Haldenwang.
Haldenwangen, ja genau, hast du auch richtig gehabt, ja? Das waren Rechtsradikaler Nazi.
Jetzt fragst du dich, wie kriegt er, ey weißt du, wie kriegt der Verfassungsschutz, kann noch nicht mal seine eigenen Leute prüfen? Und hat dann als Personenschützer für den für den Chef Nazi abgestellt, der kann's mir doch nicht erzählen.
Also, na ja, okay, lassen.
Also besser mit Nazis aus als Nazis das. So kompetente Kräfte.
Ja, genau. Er hat eigentlich einen strammen Eindruck gemacht.
Nur so kannst du dich heutzutage noch gegen Nazis äh verteidigen, indem du dich mit Nazis verteidigst.
Das war nämlich hier auch der Hauptgrund, warum dann äh hier Saskia Esken äh Vorsitzende,
der SPD sich dann diesem Vorhaben doch gebeugt hat. Die war ursprünglich dagegen, hat nämlich gesagt, ja, okay, in Ordnung machen wir jetzt doch mit, weil immerhin, wir müssen ja gegen diese ganzen Nazis vorgehen
Und das machst du jetzt ausgerechnet mit deinem von Nazis durchsetzten Geheimdienst.
Indem du dem Staatstrojaner gibst. Na ja, jetzt äh okay, kommen wir zur abschließenden Bewertung. Das andere also zur technischen auch. Ähm.
Wenn du einen Staatstrainer auf ein Gerät anbringen möchtest, dann heißt das, du bringst da eine Software drauf an, die die ähm Person da nicht haben möchte.
Ähm dafür gibt es prinzipiell zwei Wege.
Der eine Weg ist, du hast eine Schwachstelle, nutzt die aus und schaffst so diese Installation deines Staatstrojaners auf diesem Gerät. Ähm das ist ähm.
Das kann auch eine äh ja menschliche Schwachstelle sein. Hier in dem Beispiel äh der Türkei wurde das Ding äh mehr oder weniger einfach zum Download angeboten und den Leuten gesagt, hier das ist die Oppositionsapp, ne? Ähm.
Du kannst aber natürlich auch potenziell irgendwie ein Explode haben in irgendeinem PDF oder so, wo wo du beim äh Anschauen dieses äh,
dieser Datei aus dem aus der Sandbox ausbrichst und das Gerät infizierst, ne? Das ist der sehr teure Weg dann.
Und es gibt einen sehr plumpen und sehr einfachen Weg, ähm der umso krasser ist, nämlich einfach zu sagen.
Beispielsweise Apple,
ist jetzt verpflichtet oder die Deutsche Telekom wird verpflichtet dabei zu helfen, dass dieser Staatstrojaner auf das Endgerät aufgespielt wird,
und zwar ganz einfach im Rahmen eines Updates. Das heißt, du kriegst ein Update für deine ähm was weiß ich, für deine,
Signal oder was auch immer für Apps man so offen Handy benutzt.
Und dieses ist dann mit einer dieses spezifische Update für dich ist ein anderes als das, was alle anderen kriegen und das ist mit einer versehen. Und.
Das ist das, was sie mit diesem Gesetz jetzt auch erlauben, ja? Und nicht nur erlauben, sondern die Internetanbieter verpflichten dabei mitzuhelfen. Und das ist ähm.
Auf gewisse Weise, auf Anhieb denkt man sich, ach geil, technisch gesehen ist das echt die beste Lösung, weil du machst du kannst alle Sicherheitslücken immer schließen, du gefährdest nicht die Allgemeinheit.
Du kannst auch spezifisch, ne, dann eine Vektor nur für Signe, nur für Telegramm machen und äh Event hat tatsächlich dann halt auch.
Ja, halbwegs stabiler Aussage, den Unterschied zwischen,
Onlinedurchsuchung und Staatstrojaner äh und und Quellen TKÜ,
behaupten, indem du sagst, ja wir haben eben eine Vektor in Skype eingebaut und in nichts anderes. Und deswegen konnten wir auch nur Skype abfangen. Ja, das ist alles richtig. Aber das kommt zu dem Preis,
dass du der gesamten Gesellschaft das Vertrauen in Updates nimmst.
Und in ihren eigenen Telefonanbieter oder in ihren eigenen,
Hersteller ihres Mobilfunkgerätes. Ja und.
Das ist ja also das finde ich ja also ist ja absoluter Irrsinn, ne, weil weil die Leute vertrauen ja darauf ein,
integeres äh Betriebssystem zu haben und die Vertrauen auch darauf, dass wenn sie Updates machen, dass das gut ist,
wenn die Leute jetzt irgendwann an aufhören, Updates zu machen, weil sie sagen, wer weiß, ob mir dann nicht der militärische Abschirmdienst äh oder das äh Landes äh Amt für Verfassungsschutz von
des Saarlandes, ja? Mir irgendwie hier 'n Trojaner unterschiebt.
Dann muss man sich überlegen, zu welchem Preis das kommt und das ist natürlich der wieder der absolute Wahnsinn.
Ja, nicht nur zu diesem zu diesem Preis, also der sich ja dann auch in wirtschaftlicher Aktivität und Vertrauen in den Staat als solchen ähm Niederschlägt, sondern halt auch nochmal den Kontext vom Anfang aufmachen.
Verfassungsschutz, ja, die irgendwie Probleme haben, irgendwie Nazis auf zwei Meter zu erkennen, weil sie irgendwie die ganze Zeit noch äh Personenschützer äh vor sich herlaufen haben, die irgendwie die ganze Zeit den Arm nicht runterkriegen
ja? Die sollen also jetzt sozusagen ohne Berichtspflichtig sein, Zugriff bekommen auf potentiell jedes Telefon, um dann da irgendwas zu tun und benutzen sie sozusagen genau dieselben Hacking Tools, die auch jeder anderen Demokratie verkauft werden,
Äh ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut rüberkommt. Bei mir kommt es auf jeden Fall nicht gut an. Und das äh das ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, diese,
ewige Erzählung, ne, also meine mich ja auch noch erinnern zu können, so in den Achtzigern, Neunzigern.
Quasi dieses Überwachungsding und dieses Zugriff auf auf äh digitale Infrastrukturen schon ein Thema im CCC, während die Öffentlichkeit sich ja eigentlich immer noch in so einem,
Blümchenmodus befand mit ja Nazis das war früher das ja das Hitler ist besiegt und jetzt jetzt sind wir ja die total geile äh Demokratie. Und unser Argument war ja immer so.
Ja, aber was was ist, wenn's halt wieder kommt? Nur dass ich das halt damals so richtig keiner vorstellen kann. Das kann man sich, glaube ich, heute,
nicht mehr so richtig vorstellen, dass man sich damals nicht vorstellen konnte, dass es wiederkommt. Aber das war immer das Argument, ne, dass man dem Staat keine Werkzeuge in die Hand gibt,
die in dem Moment äh missbraucht werden können.
Wo, sagen wir mal, die staatlichen Akteure nicht mehr so fein drauf sind, wie das derzeit ist. Das sieht man ja wunderbar auch in den USA, wo,
Alle Stricke reißen, wo es einfach keinerlei Kontrollmechanismen mehr gibt oder zumindest keine gibt, die noch greifen, um diesem wütenden Trump in irgendeiner Form seinen republikanischen Kronis in irgendeiner Form noch etwas entgegenzusetzen,
Selbst wenn die Wahrheitslage vollkommen klar ist und äh ein Staat in seinen Mitteln und seinen ähm,
anwendbaren Werkzeugen zu beschränken ist ein grundsätzliches Prinzip. Da kann man jetzt Angela Merkel noch so geil finden und glauben, dass dass ja alles immer toll sein wird.
Es gibt dafür halt einfach gar keine Garantie und deswegen müssen wir auch die Werkzeuge beschränken.
Die jetzt Leuten zur Verfügung gestellt werden, die vielleicht ganz toll sind. Und alles richtig gut meinen. Das sind dann einfach die falschen Werkzeuge,
Nein, du brauchst keine Schrotflinte, um hier irgendwie einen Ladendieb äh festzunehmen, brauchst du einfach nicht.
Und es ist auch, also ich meine, wenn man sich mal anschaut, wer also man darf ja immer nicht vergessen, dass die ja Ermittlungserfolge haben.
Und es wird immer davon ausgegangen, dass was weiß ich, diese verschlüsselte Kommunikation, dass dass das große, schwere Problem sei. Du hast immer noch sackweise Metadaten. Du hast immer noch ähm.
Ein leichtes Spiel, insbesondere äh also wenn du dir jetzt mal anschaust, ne, das nächste, was ja hier so gerade so als die die Gefahr, wir haben's ja gerade so gesagt.
Das nächste wo die Nazis jetzt viel Spaß mit haben so ungefähr sind diese diese Verschwörungstheorien um Corona, ja? Jetzt wird ja schon, das ist natürlich jetzt wird jetzt spekuliert,
dass am dritten Oktober, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, hat hier auf der Berliner Museumsinsel irgendwie ein Anschlag auf insgesamt siebzig Exponate stattgefunden,
wo die mit einer öligen Flüssigkeit beschmiert wurden, ne. Jetzt wird spekuliert.
Dass das unter Umständen, also ich meine, das hast du immer wieder, ne, dass irgendwelche geistesgestörten,
Kunst oder Kulturgüter beschädigen, ne? Das ist ein Phänomen, das gibt, kann also auch einfach in ganz normaler Geistes gestörter sein, aber weil sich gerade die ganzen Geistesgestörten bei Attila Hildmann sammeln,
der äh in seinem Telegram-Kanal äh darauf hingewiesen hat, dass äh auf der,
Im Pergamon Museum der Thron des Satans sitzt und dass da die.
Durch die Bundesregierung stattfinden, wird.
Entschuldigung, jetzt fange ich auch schon an, das irgendwie wiederzugeben.
Äh wird halt jetzt ein äh ein wird da der Verdacht äh gehegt, dass das potenziell mit dessen Äußerungen zu tun haben könnte, ne? Dass einer von seinen äh ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, der hat äh so,
den folgen achtzigtausend Leute äh auf Telegram, aber wenn der so einen Poll macht, ne, dann,
immer ein Drittel Kontra. Also der hat ja dann irgendwie so ist ganz gut. Also da sind mindestens ein Drittel da drin sind auch einfach so äh ja völkische Beobachter sein.
Entschuldigung, Leute, die sich dann einfach nur eher angewidert anschauen und denen und mal ein bisschen gucken, was der, was der Wahnsinnige sich da jeden Tag Neues ausdenkt. Aber es es ist überhaupt gar kein Problem, in diese Kreise hineinzukommen
ja? Es ist nicht so, als wäre das schwierig, das zu unterwandern. Ne, und ähm das wäre eben auch mal,
sinnvoll sich diese äh diese Mühe zu machen.
Muss man sich ja nur die ganzen Einzelfälle anschauen, die jetzt irgendwie in der Polizei am laufenden Meter.
Jeden Tag nur einen Einzelfall.
Jeden Tag nur ein Einzelfall. Ja, die sitzen am Ende sitzen die alle auch auf dem Tro des Satan.
Wie den Attila hielt man da irgendwie auf der Museumsinsel ausgemacht haben will, ne? Also ich meine das ist das sind wieder schön
Beste Beispiel ist diese antisemitische Punkte ohne Rückkehr ist auch schon wieder komplett überschritten worden.
Währenddessen vielleicht noch ganz kurz zum Thema äh Staatstrainer, ne, es ist nicht so, als würden die Five Eyes nicht weiter auch an dem Thema dranbleiben. Die haben jetzt gerade wieder,
vor ein paar Tagen so 'ne so ein Appel veröffentlicht, also die Five Ice Indien und Japan,
appellieren an die Digitalwirtschaft auf Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung zu verzichten. Geil, oder?
Indien und Japan aber.
Indien, Japan und die Five Ice, ja? Möchten sie äh ernsthaftes Risiko für die öffentliche Sicherheit? Sie sollen in Kooperation mit ihnen vernünftige technisch machbare Lösungen entwickeln im Falls Eisverbund,
ne, haben wir die NSA GCHQ und so weiter, ne? Also Five Eyes sind ja die ganzen,
das ehemalige Reich der Krone so ungefähr, ne? Großbritannien, USA, äh Australien.
Neuseeland und wer ist der Fünfte? Kanada.
Ja und äh jetzt wage ich eine vorsichtige Schätzung, ich glaube.
Dass es darauf hinausgehen hinauslaufen wird.
Dass sie diese ähm Kooperation der Anbieter, also sei es jetzt, ne, von mir aus die.
Diejenigen, die die App bereitstellen, ähm diejenigen, die die Plattform iOS oder Android bereitstellen.
Oder eventuell eben äh sonstige äh ähm Anbieter,
Dass es da dahin gehen wird, dass sie die zur Mitarbeit verpflichten. Und ich glaube, der Grund, warum sie das tun werden, ist tatsächlich, wenn du wirklich,
Staatstrojaner im Sinne von, du musst wirklich ein Gerät hacken und zwar ein Gerät, was Apple oder Google sicher gemacht haben. Ähm,
dass das auf Dauer einfach zu teuer wird für die,
Schwachstellen zu kaufen und so weiter. Ähm während sie, wenn sie die Anbieter verpflichten mitzuwirken und äh quasi gezielte,
dort der Einzelprogramme auszurollen in dieses Problem nicht mehr haben mit äh also das Problem ähm das.
Sie eine Schwachstelle auf dem Gerät brauchen, ja? Ähm,
Sie können auch, äh Sie haben auch das Problem, dann eventuell nicht mehr, dass das dass das Betriebssystem trotzdem in der Lage wäre, die Schadsoftware zu entdecken,
und sie haben eben das Problem nicht mehr, dass Schwachstellen vorhanden sein müssen, die den Rest der Gesellschaft bedrohen. Deswegen glaube ich, dass früher oder später der Hase dahin laufen wird, dass sie die
Anbieter und zwar, das kann dann eben sein Anbieter der App, Anbieter des App Stores, wer auch immer, dass sie die,
verpflichten. Und genau das hat Deutschland jetzt auch grade getan und genau da wird der Hase langlaufen und ich sage das ist trotzdem
ganz, ganz fürchterlich, weil es letztendlich das Vertrauen der Menschen in ihr eigenes technisches Gerät schmälert, ja? Ähm und.
Weil diejenigen, die es wollen, das habe ich so oft gesagt, trotzdem verschlüsselt kommunizieren,
werden. Die werden sich ganz einfach irgendwelche Minimallinoxe machen und darüber ihre eigene,
irgendeine Quell offene Krypto ohne für ein Kommunikationsweg ihrer Wahl machen. Und es ist völlig ausgeschlossen, dass man sich vor dieser technischen Entwicklung, dass man die irgendwie,
verhindern kann. Es wird einfach nicht passieren. Man wird sich auf eine Welt einrichten müssen, in der verschlüsselt,
man muss eben mit entsprechenden Methoden arbeiten, aber dafür sind sie zu faul und dass sie deswegen ist diese Strategie tatsächlich.
In so vielen Richtungen katastrophal. Weil sie weil sie, wenn sie diese Strategie weiter fahren, sie den Anschluss an das Verbrechen drohen zu verlieren, wenn sie sich nur darauf konzentrieren, äh irgendwelche Handys zu hängen.
Na ja, also das, das, da, wie gesagt, ne, wir sind hier immer noch im Bereich äh Actiony Happent, ja?
Man muss ja äh vielleicht nochmal kurz betonen, wir reden jetzt von einem Kabinettsbeschluss in Deutschland, ja, also ist noch nicht verabschiedet, äh aber ist sozusagen das erklärte Ziel der Bundesregierung und da muss man erstmal gucken, wie man da noch Druck ausüben kann.
Kabinettsbeschlüsse werden als Gesetzesvorschläge in den Bundestag herabgereicht und dann wird ein äh Bundestagsausschuss Ausschuss
eventuell der Rechtsausschuss. Bisher war es immer der Rechtsausschuss, äh der sich mit solchen Staatsrädern erfragen auseinandergesetzt hat. Zuletzt war ich dort,
zwanzig siebzehn als Sachverständiger.
Als es um die Ausweitung der Staatstrojaner Rechte der Polizei auf,
sagen wir mal, von von Kinder Kindesmissbrauch und Terror auf äh ja, letztendlich Alltagskriminalität ging. Da war ich als Sachverständiger da. Äh Ulf Promeier glaube ich übrigens auch, wenn ich mich recht entsinne. Wir saßen nebeneinander.
Und ähm dieser Gesetzesentwurf hier Thema Geheimdienste wird im Zweifelsfall dann eben auch wieder in einem,
Ausschuss verhandelt werden. Ähm,
Ich würde mich freuen, sofern ich da dieses Mal als Sachverständiger geladen werde, vielleicht früher als zwei Tage vor der Anhörung Bescheid zu bekommen.
Dann kannst du dich doch vorbereiten.
Ja, genau so.
Am Ende bringst du noch überzeugende Argumente.
Weiß ich noch damals. Da habe ich, da habe ich na die Argumente, die kann ich so runterschreiben. Das wird jetzt also nein, nein, nein, nein, kann ich nicht, ich brauche äh.
So
Schauen wir nochmal in die USA. Da äh ja, sieht es so aus, als ob die.
Die Rechtschaffenheit des Staates sich gegen Google einschießt ein wenig,
Und zwar ist es überhaupt in den letzten Monaten dieses ganze Ding mit was ist denn nun mit unseren großen digitalen Companies und missbrauchen die,
ihre Macht in irgendeiner Form. Das war ja ein ganz großes Thema. Es gab da so ein großes Anhörungs äh Event, wo sie irgendwie alle,
von so Apple, Google, Facebook. Ah, warte mal, es waren glaube ich fünf äh wer war da noch dabei?
War der Twitter-Typ auch noch dabei, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau.
Wie nennt man die nochmal.
Amazon, Amazon noch äh war noch dabei.
Garba nennt man die doch immer, ne? Google, Amazon.
Ja, je nachdem, welche Gruppe die rund du jetzt gerade machen willst oder so, ne, aber es gibt ja so im Wesentlichen so diese Big Five. Äh und zwar insofern schon ein bisschen absurd, weil natürlich,
die Gemengelage dann doch in den einzelnen Unternehmen ganz andere ist, ne? Facebook
Twitter, da geht's halt im Wesentlichen um diese ganze Achse fähigs äh Fake News, äh Werbung, irgendwie modifizierte Timelines, was wird hochgespielt et cetera hatten wir jetzt hier auch schon. Dann äh hast du bei
Apple, was ging's halt mehr in Richtung so App Store und so weiter äh ja äh ist das jetzt ein Monopol?
Auch äh so oder so sehen kann. Und bei Google geht's halt ähm mehr eigentlich um ihre Dominanz des Suchmaschinenmarktes. Und dort gibt's jetzt halt auch einen neuen,
Kartellverfahren äh eingeleitet worden und es wird halt äh Google Missbrauch.
Seiner Marktmacht vorgeworfen im Bereich der Suchmaschinen und es wird so auf Bundesebene angestoßen und äh gibt wohl aber auch zwölf Bundesstaaten, die sich hier diesem Vorgehen anschließen.
Und generell werden halt sowohl Strafen äh als auch eben strukturelle Maßnahmen gefordert, also sprich eine Änderung der,
entweder der Gesetzgebung, die bestimmte Konstellationen künftig verhindert, bis hin eben zu einer Zerschlagung von Google und in in bestimmte Teile, um da eben über Konkurrenzsystem. Äh eine,
Monopol macht aufzubrechen.
Kann man da beim Suchbereich gut machen, so nach dem Alphabet?
Ach so, Google sucht jetzt nur noch von A bis F.
Deswegen ja genau, Elfebett darf jetzt nur noch von A bis F suchen.
Genau. Kuh wird rausgenommen irgendwie das äh Greta kriegt seine eigene Suchmaschine.
Na ja, also ähm,
Es gibt es gab ja auch in Europa bereits ähm Strafen für Google, da ging's aber eben um die Bevorzugung von Shopping-Links. Das war, sagen wir mal, eher eine relativ konkrete Geschichte,
und die Strafen sind ja auch schon aus äh gesprochen worden und
sogar auch schon bezahlt worden, das weiß ich nicht, weil eben über Suche dann eben Shoppingportale bedient wurden, wo dann Google irgendwie selber äh seiner Form sich eingeklinkt hat. Das ist natürlich,
hochproblematisch und würde sagen an der Stelle auch relativ klar entscheidbar. Ich finde jetzt diese ganze Aufstellung mit ihr habt da ein Monopol,
Ist halt schwierig. Also es geht ja jetzt gar nicht so sehr um ich lasse mal das den Begriff Monopol raus, weil er ist ein bisschen schwierig. Aber sie haben eine Marktmacht. Das ist ja nur vollkommen klar. Google hat irgendwie, je nachdem, wohin du schaust, ähm,
Im westlichen Teil der Welt äh doch erhebliche Marktanteile, die vielleicht hier mal bei neunzig und damals bei bei fünfundneunzig liegen. Ich glaube, in Deutschland ist es eher relativ stark, in USA auch, anderen Ländern.
Verteilt sich's noch ein bisschen anders, aber sie sind mehr oder weniger überall Platzhirsch, wenn's nicht um China geht. Und.
Ja, jetzt wird halt sowohl, also ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt, was,
Okay, was werft ihr denn jetzt eigentlich konkret vor? Ja, ich meine, gut, sie verdienen ja über diese Suche, verdienen sie Geld. Und natürlich ist es, sagen wir mal, problematisch, dass sie in ihrer Suche bezahlte Links.
Höher renkenken, ja, dass sie sich quasi für die richtige Reihenfolge der Suchergebnisse implizit oder explizit bezahlen lassen. Das problematisch.
Ist das jetzt aber eine Folge ihrer Marktmacht? Oder könnte das nicht im Prinzip jede Suchmaschine tun?
Also ich meine, was würde denn jetzt zum Beispiel davon abhalten, das gleiche zu tun? Außer, dass sie halt nicht ganz so viel.
Impact haben. So, aber ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass wenn die gute Suchmaschine auf diese Art und Weise funktioniert.
Andere da automatisch da drunter leiden und sie in irgendeiner Form ihre ihre Macht ausnutzen, um diese Position äh zu zementieren.
Nicht sicher, ob du da den den äh den Blick auf den Markt beherrschende Stellung richtig hast. Äh also aus.
Bin ich mir auch nicht sicher. Du kannst da gerne äh was zu sagen.
Weil in diesem Fall wäre die Marktbeherrschende Stellung, dass Google nicht nur mein den Markt über meine Suchanfragen kontrolliert, sondern den aus Anbietersicht den Markt über.
Ich möchte gefunden werden.
Kontrolliert, ja? Also der quasi wenn Google das macht, ist das etwas anderes, als wenn Doctor Goders macht, weil Doctor Go äh eben, was weiß ich, ein halbes Prozent der weltweiten Suchanfragen dir anbieten kann und Google neunundneunzig.
Ja? Und dann googel eben dir als Werbetreibender gegenüber einem Markt,
beherrschende Stellung hat, die sie ausnutzen können. Und die verbinden können mit ach, du willst bei suchen gefunden werden, aber du kannst gar nicht bezahlen, dann macht das wahrscheinlich gar keinen Sinn, wenn dich überhaupt jemand findet.
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, inwiefern ist das, ist diese Marktmacht.
Ausgenutzt oder inwiefern existiert sie nur? Ich meine, wir haben auch andere Unternehmen, die eine große Marktmacht haben, weil sie einfach in ihrem Treiben sehr erfolgreich sind. Und es ist ja auch so, dass Google extrem viel Geld dafür bezahlt,
um auf anderen Plattformen, die sie eben nicht kontrollieren, äh überhaupt ähm in dem Maße präsent zu sein, also.
Ja, was wiederum das Ausnutzen einer Markt beherrschenden Stellung ist, weil sie das Geld haben. Und damit äh.
Ja näher. Gut, das das kann man natürlich,
also weiß ich nicht, ob das sozusagen jetzt schon ausreichende Sichtweise ist. Man könnte auch argumentieren mit sie müssen ja sogar dafür bezahlen, um
überhaupt eine Macht an der Stelle zu haben. Also sie kaufen sich bei Apple und bei Google äh äh bei schon nicht gut, kauft sie nicht bei Google. Bei Samsung, Motorroller und so weiter, also andere führende Hersteller,
Plattformen. Denen müssen sie Milliardenbeträge bezahlen, also,
Klare Zahlen gibt's nicht, aber ich kenne so die Vermutung, dass also äh Google allein an Apple mehrere Milliarden pro Jahr äh abplatzt. Einfach nur, um die Folls Suchmaschine zu sein. Nichts anderes. Man kann das auch immer noch ändern.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt sozusagen Ausdruck von Marktmacht ist, dass man da,
für diesen Zugriff äh bezahlen muss. Marktmacht wäre, wenn sie in irgendeiner Form Apple dazu zwingen könnten, sich äh sie als Dir voll zu machen, ohne diese Zahlungen zu leisten. Also so würde ich das zumindest jetzt erstmal sehen.
Könnt ihr auch jemand anders bezahlen.
Ja, äh also da bin ich mir also dafür kennen wir, glaube ich, das Kartellrecht nicht äh gut genug. Ähm.
Um das hier zu beurteilen. Ich denke, ehrlich gesagt, schon, dass außer Frage ist, dass Google eine Markt beherrschende Stellung hat und ich kann mir schwer vorstellen, wie man eine Markt beherrschende Stellung nicht missbrauchen könnte.
Die eigentliche Botschaft, die, glaube ich, ein bisschen dahinter steckt, ist also klar, ich sehe da auch ein Problem, ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, da da gibt es jetzt kein Problem. Ich habe bloß einen zunehmenden Maße, das Gefühl, dass dieses Kartellrecht.
Was ja quasi von ganz anderen Voraussetzungen ausgegangen ist, was aus einer Zeit kommt, in dem wir eben diese Effekte, wie wir sie heute in der digitalen Welt haben, so nicht mehr existieren
einfach nicht mehr angemessen ist
Also es kann sehr wohl sein, dass dass es einfach zu kurz greift oder Dinge falsch definiert. Weil Markt macht in dem Sinne sich hier einfach durch diese Netzwerkeffekte äh zementiert. Die Leute benutzen ja Facebook, weil alle anderen auch Facebook benutzen.
Und äh ähnlich ist es äh in gewisser Hinsicht.
Na, ist nicht ähnlich. Nochmal ein bisschen anders. Also, es gibt einfach andere Kräfte, dieses Gewohnheitsdinger verbreitet, äh klar äh du findest,
auf Google auch einfach am besten. Also muss man ja auch mal sagen, ich meine, sie sind, sie sind halt auch die besten.
Also ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt sie mit einem minderwertigen Dienst auf einmal den Markt behalten.
Wenn ich jetzt schlechte Ergebnisse liefern würden, dann würden sie darunter auch leiden.
Und und die Kräfte, die sie hier ausspielen, sind halt mit dem Besteck des normalen Kartellrechts,
meiner Auffassung nach nur unzureichend zu greifen, ja. Man muss letzten Endes darüber nachdenken. Also
Letztlich können wir auch nicht mehr sagen, als dieses Verfahren existiert. Es gibt sozusagen äh da einen Wunschgut, einen vor die Kahn zu fahren
Was aber am Ende da auch die Motivation der einzelnen Akteure ist, ja, ich meine, es gibt dann irgendwie Trump, der sagt so, na ja, ihr müsst ja mal mehr über republikanische äh äh Quellen hier berichten und wir werden ja unterdrückt,
was bisschen absurd ist, wenn man sich so anschaut, was so auf Facebook am meisten rumgeht. Ähm aber,
so ist an der Stelle die Argumentation und hier könnt ihr eben ein Stück weit auch dieses der Staat will sich wiederum.
Ähm einmischen in in einen Bereich, in dem man sich vielleicht unter Umständen auch raushalten sollte. Keine Ahnung,
Also ich finde zumindest, es steht ein bisschen auf wackeligen Füßen und man muss äh mal abwarten, was dabei rauskommt.
Also ich denke, hm, wird sich auf jeden Fall Gedanken darüber machen müssen. Also verstehe zum Beispiel auch nicht, warum man sich jetzt Google schnappt und nicht Facebook, ne.
Also bei Facebook sehe ich, dass zum Beispiel sehr viel eher ähm weil.
Kann ich auch zeigen, weil die sich ja im Prinzip ihre Konkurrenz auch kaufen. Es ist ja so, wenn du siehe Instagram, siehe WhatsApp.
Ja? Und da ähm und ich tatsächlich bei Facebook also auch das viel größere ähm ekelhaftere Schadenspotential für.
Unsere Gesellschaft sehe. Äh jetzt ist natürlich äh Google ist mit YouTube jetzt auch nicht äh auch kein Kind von Traurigkeit, was jetzt den,
die die allgemeine Verblödung der Menschheit angeht, ne? Aber ähm bei so insgesamt scheint mir Facebook da noch ein bisschen kritischer zu sein. Und.
Wäre schon nicht schlecht, diese Macht dieser Unternehmen und das äh das sage ich jetzt unabhängig von einem wirtschaftlichen Argument.
In irgendeiner Weise äh zu zerstören oder zu äh zu kontrollieren. Weil die Macht, die diese Unternehmen haben, weltweit, ja? Und das ist das ist viel mehr als eine Frage von irgendwie US-amerikanischem Kartellrecht,
ist so enorm, dass es wahrscheinlich für die Menschheit nicht gut ist.
Es ist ganz anderes Argument als ein wirtschaftliches, aber äh so prinzipiell den Laden diese diese Dinger zu zerschlagen.
Erschiene mir nicht so falsch, wobei, wie gesagt, in einem, wie ich sehr oft hier, dass ich ja sehr oft hier betone, sehr wichtigen Buch, äh, wie Intention Mergens, ähm, von Tim Woo und.
Das ist sogar in dem in dem anderen Buch sowieso Switch. Ich weiß nicht, ob's the Kill Switch heißt oder so was. Ähm.
Master Switch. Master Switch.
The Master Switch, genau. Ähm wo er äh Kartellbildung ähm,
Erstmal der macht erstmal eine Historie der Kartellbildung in äh Kommunikationsmedien. Ja, also Telefonie,
und TV, äh wo er das dann auch sehr behandelt und eben auch sagt, so ja, ja klar, dann hat sie am Ende zerschlagen in in vier Teile der USA, aber äh besser ist es dadurch auch nicht geworden, ne.
Dann dann dominieren die eben jeweils nur noch ein ein Viertel der USA ja ähm.
Den Amazon Link für die beiden Bücher können wir gerne machen. Mache ich übrigens wieder äh mache ich äh Affiliate Links. Das ist doch schön. Mache ich Affiliate Links raus.
Und dann machen wir auch noch was hier äh faire Buchhandel links. Aber die also da müsst ihr dann wissen, kriege ich kein Geld.
Ähm aber Google, jetzt haben wir schon hier fast so ein bisschen Mitleid mit Google.
Ja, das arme Gurgel, ey. Och, ja.
Arme Google? Was macht das Google sonst noch so in seiner.
Andere Google speicherte halt auch ganz äh fleißig und da gibt's äh durchaus auch größeres Interesse dadran. Unter anderem.
US-Behörden in zunehmenden Maße aufgespeicherte Verbindungs- und Standortdaten bei.
Den Suchmaschinenfunktionen zu.
Und äh das ist jetzt auch bekannt geworden durch so einen Gerichtsfall, der ein bisschen äh tiefer dokumentiert wurde, was denn da so äh abgegangen ist, hinter den,
Kulissen und um ja hier weitere Informationen zu kommen, wurden wohl tatsächlich von den Ermittlern IP-Adressen von Nutzern.
Angefragt, bei Google.
Und zwar jetzt nicht von hier dieser Benutzer, den haben wir im Auge. Bitte mal hier Vorratsdaten oder sowas äh liefern. Ja, also der der Klassiker, den man jetzt äh eigentlich immer diskutiert haben. Nee, nee, sondern,
Hier wurde quasi richtig recherchiert und man hat Googles Daten benutzt um herauszufinden wer hat denn in einer bestimmten Zeit nach einer bestimmten Adresse in Florida,
gegoogelt. Also man hatte da quasi so ein Zielobjekt und hat vermutet, dass irgendjemand diese Adresse gesucht hat
und ähm das war dann wohl erfolgreich, darüber hat man IP-Adressen bekommen, über diese IP-Adresse hat man dann wiederum
Zugang zu einem Telefonanschluss bekommen, darüber hatte man dann
über den Abgleich dieser Telefonnummer könnte man dann eben auf den Mobilfunk gehen und Funkzellenabfrage machen und so eine Kaskade von Ermittlungen eingeleitet.
Um dann letzten Endes eine Person zu ermitteln.
Also Rasterfahndung auf Suchanfragen.
Ja, so könnte man das vielleicht auch nennen, ja. Und ja, das ist ähm,
und Geber, dass äh so etwas gemacht wird, auch teilweise also über Google, äh Maps und, und, und, und, und die Maps-Funktionen auf äh an und äh ja,
sogenannte Geo-Fans abfragen, äh um einfach auch zu gucken, wer hat sich denn hier irgendwo aufgehalten,
ja? Und ähm,
Daten existieren und auf diese Daten wird zugegriffen. Ähm auf welcher Rechtsbasis kann ich nicht sagen, aber wir wissen, die Wege sind da in den USA und das heißt, es war relativ kurz.
Da ist nicht jeder glücklich drüber, also da gibt's wohl auch bei Google bei den Mitarbeitern selber eine ganze Menge Frustration in dieser ähm Hinsicht und ähm.
Jetzt ist halt die Frage, was äh soll dagegen getan werden? Es gibt also Leute, die sich äh dagegen aussprechen, aber es ist halt eher so äh in Richtung mit der Staat darf das nicht nutzen als.
Google darf das gar nicht erst speichern. Ich meine, das Problem entsteht ja immer wieder, dass ja hier auch so eine wiederkehrende Erzählung bei uns,
wenn man erstmal die Daten hat, dann entstehen die Begehrlichkeiten. Und es ist sehr schwieriger, sich gegen diese Begehrlichkeiten äh zu wenden als von vorneherein zu sagen.
Nicht so viele Daten. Das ist ja auch dieses Grundthema in den ganzen Datenschutzdebatten. Wir hatten das auch bei dieser Corona
Warn-App ja auch immer wieder dieses ja warum sollen wir uns denn beschränken? Warum sollen wir uns denn beschränken? Wir sollen uns beschränken damit
gar nicht erst Begehrlichkeiten entstehen, weil in dem Moment, wo man sich ein System ausdenkt, wo solche Daten anfallen, die zwar zu irgendeinem sinnvollen Zweck vielleicht gesammelt werden, die aber eben hohes Missbrauch,
Potenzial haben, dann wird dieses Missbrauchspotential irgendwann auch von jemandem entdeckt und gefordert werden. Und äh das ist natürlich hier,
bei Google extrem, weil jeder, der sich mal seine eigene Suchhistorie anschaut, wird schnell wissen,
Wenn man sich das durchliest, man sehr viel darüber weiß, wie man es, wer man ist und wann man wie war und wo
und ja, das bewegt weckt natürlich die Begehrlichkeiten und wenn's halt,
nachvollziehbar ist, dass es im Rahmen einer Strafverfolgung von irgendeinem ganz bösen Fall, äh wo man sagt, so haja, hier, ne, schwerste Kriminalfälle
schwerste Straftaten, wie es ja auch immer eine Argumentation heißt, bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung nur dafür, sodass er benutzt werden, aber dann schaut man sich am Ende die Auswertung an und stellt fest
kleinen Scheiß wird benutzt und natürlich um auch wieder auf die Erzählung zu Beginn dieser Sendung zurückgehen.
Potentielles Missbrauchspotenzial eines repressiven Staates, der dann halt einfach solche Suchanfragen auch mit ja, wer.
Wer macht denn hier Suchanfragen nach wo ist denn die nächste Demo? Wer macht denn hier Suchanfragen mit
wo ist denn hier der der nächste äh Organisator eines Protestes gegen äh Lukaschenko in Weißrussland? Also das ist halt einfach ein Werkzeug, mit dem man eben die totale Unterdrückung auch wunderbar automatisieren könnte.
Und deswegen ist es schon mal generell problematisch, dass so eine Daten überhaupt in dieser Form vorgehalten werden, dass sie so so leicht deanonymisiert werden können und eben die IP-Adressen da zum Beispiel mitzuspeichern, ist schon mal,
kleines Verbrechen.
Herrje. Jetzt wäre, es wäre schön, wenn wir jetzt endlich fertig werden, aber es kommt ja noch was. Aber dieses Thema hatten wir schon, deswegen behandeln wir das eher kurz. Ähm und zwar.
Terror, Terror.
Genau, Uploadfilter, Terror. Ähm.
Thomas hat es hier öfter erzählt, wir haben's äh wie gesagt, wir haben's auf dem Schirm. Es gibt die Content Online Regulation, mit der die Europäische Kommission jetzt die Verbreitung terroristischer Inhalte im Internet verhindern möchte
und jetzt,
befindet sich diese TCO in dem in den Trilog, den Verhandlungen zwischen Parlamentkommission und den äh Mitgliedsstaaten,
und jetzt tatsächlich haben wir grade die deutsche Ratspräsidentschaft ja.
Und das ist ja äh in Person von äh warte wer, Moment, jetzt komme ich die.
Kommissionspräsidentin ist Ursula von der Leyen.
Und die Ratspräsidentschaft, das ist im Prinzip dann nämlich die Merkel, die Bundesregierung, ne? So.
Also, wir haben hier Zensursular und äh und Merkel äh die jetzt natürlich gemeinsam sagen, alles klar, da wollen wir doch am besten mal einen Uploadfilter drin haben in dieser Terriscontent online Regulation.
Ähm also und zwar sollen Mitgliedsstaaten, die nach äh die als sollen.
Inhalte, die von einem Mitgliedsstaat nach eigenem Ermessen als terroristisch eingestuft werden innerhalb von einer Stunde gelöscht werden und ein erneutes Hochladen verhindert werden. So, sehr komplizierter Satz, interessant ist,
Also erneutes Hochladen verhindert werden, heißt Uploadfilter,
Innerhalb von einer Stunde löschen, heißt erstmal relativ schnell reagieren, Tag und Nacht, ja? Und was krass ist, von einem Mitgliedsstaat nach eigenem Ermessen eingestuft, heißt.
Das gilt auch für eine deutsche Anbieterin, wenn der Inhalt von, sagen wir mal, äh einer ähm.
Ungarischen äh Behörde als terroristisch eingestuft wird.
Also du hast einen direkt Zugriff von äh aus dem EU-Ausland. Das kann hier quasi ungeprüfte Löschbefehle auf deutschen Plattformen äh abgeben,
ja ähm und zwar äh vierundzwanzig sieben und die Plattformen müssen innerhalb einer Stunde reagieren. Und sie müssen danach äh einen Uploadfilter in Place haben, um das erneute Hochladen zu verhindern.
Uploadfilter, wie gesagt, ein nicht geringer Aufwand, der beim Hochladen getrieben werden muss, um quasi.
Einen Inhalt gegen.
Die Liste der gesperrten Inhalte äh zu prüfen. Gleichzeitig hast du dann bei der Liste der gesperrten Inhalte ähm.
Natürlich sehr viel und dann ein Inhalt kann ja auch marginal verändert werden, ne? In dem Moment, wo du einen Pixel in einem Bild änderst, ist das jetzt ohne weiteren Rechenaufwand,
nicht von nicht sofort als das gleiche zu erkennen, ja? Der Rechenaufwand kann eben steigen, je nachdem wie schwer du die oder wie wie gut du die Veränderung machst, um den Algorithmus,
quasi schwieriger zu machen, das Gleiche, den gleichen Inhalt wiederzuerkennen. Mit anderen Worten, du brauchst einen sehr großen äh Aufwand, um so einen Uploadfilter zu machen.
Und ich habe schon vor Jahren hier argumentiert, das wird dazu führen, dass der Upload-Filterbetrieb ausgelagert wird. Und dann hat es dann nämlich genau diese kleinen Plattformen, die versuchen auch mal eine Schnitte vom Markt zu bekommen,
ihren Uploadfilter teil, im Prinzip äh ähm outsourcen an Google,
und sagen, alles klar, damit sind wir den ganzen Mist wieder los. Das heißt, wir haben eine Benachteiligung kleinerer Plattform, wir haben sowieso,
ganzen Problemen, gerade hier beim Terror äh ist das ja nochmal was anderes als beim Urheberrecht, dass äh Meinungsfreiheit, äh Pressefreiheit und Forschung Lehre beeinflusst werden, denn das gleiche Bild.
Kann ja für Terrorpropaganda genauso genutzt werden wie für ähm.
Wie viel Berichterstattung oder Forschung nehmen wir ne? Hier diese typischen Bilder, um deren Verbreitung der islamische Staat äh bemüht ist, wenn sie da, ne, Amerikaner in ihre Hände bekommen haben.
Ein Foto davon kannst du was weiß ich in einer, in einer dieser in einem dieser IS-Magazine aufm Cover, ist das Terrorpropaganda aufm Time Magazin, auf dem Cover, ist es das nicht.
Ist aber das gleiche Bild. Viel Spaß mit dem äh mit dem Uploadfilter. Also es kann nur schiefgehen, ne. Und ähm.
Löschbefehle aus dem EU-Ausland finde ich natürlich auch äh.
Enorm äh unterhaltsam. Wir haben uns da jetzt auch nochmal als CCC gegen positioniert. Es ist leider so, dass das ein Thema ist, oft das sehr wenige,
auf dem irgendwie sehr wenig Aufmerksamkeit gerade haftet na? Und das.
Droht halt jetzt irgendwie da durchzukommen,
ausgerechnet Deutschland, die ja im Koalitionsvertrag stehen haben, dass sie Uploadfilter verhindern möchten.
Ja? Ausgerechnet jetzt mit einer deutschen äh äh Ratspräsidentschaft und einer deutschen äh Kommissionspräsidentin kriegen wir nochmal Uploadfilter auch nochmal für Terror.
Da verlierst du auch ähm tatsächlich die Hoffnung, weil man ja eigentlich meinte, dass insbesondere Deutschland.
In dem ja diese Diskussion und die Uploadfilter ja nochmal besonders groß geführt wurde, ja? Insbesondere in Deutschland müsste doch jetzt verstanden worden sein,
dass das wirklich eine blöde Idee ist
Aber die haben tatsächlich echt alle nur da gesessen, haben sich gedacht, auch der arme Axel Voss, der musste jetzt als erstes einmal durch den Shitstorm gehen. Wenn wir da mit der zweite mal kommen, kriegen die, kriegen die Jugendlichen ihren Arsch wieder nicht mehr hoch oder die Youtuber fühlen sich nicht so angesprochen,
Ähm und dann ähm kriegen wir die Nummer schon durch. Und ist ja gegen den Terror.
Von Zensursolar zu Terrorsolar.
Terrorursula.
Ja. Terrorosel. Ja. Gut. Nichts.
Meine Güte. Äh.
Corona worden.
Ja, es gab jetzt irgendwie, es gibt zwei neue Features in der Corona-Warn-App, leider nicht die, die äh ich verlangt habe,
man kann jetzt irgendwie äh freiwillig Krankheitssymptome eintragen, wenn man positiv getestet wurde,
damit die Warnung von Kontakten noch präziser zu machen. Ich weiß nicht genau, also ich vermute, dass sie damit aus deinem Symptom stand, äh zurück,
messen wollen, A wann warst du wohl infektiös oder so.
Ja, also das hat was mit zu tun, mit diesem sogenannten Transmissionriss Parameter. Es gibt ja bei diesen Kontakt
äh abgleichen, gibt's ja verschiedene Parameter, die mit einbezogen werden, um eine Bewertung äh vorzunehmen, ob das jetzt sozusagen ein hohes Risiko dargestellt hat oder nicht. Und da sind diese Klassiker mit Abstand, also Signalstärke, Bluetooth und wie lange hast du das gesehen, äh sozusagen so der der Grundrahmen und
wird dann nochmal übergelagert ein sogenannter Transmission Rissparameter, der quasi nach Tagen aufgeteilt ist. Und bisher war es halt so, dass ähm
schlicht die App immer angenommen hat, in dem Moment, wo du sagst, okay, ich bin jetzt infiziert
dass es sich da um einen bestimmten Tag gehandelt hat, der aber in keiner Form berücksichtigt hat, wann ist eigentlich dieser Test vorgenommen worden und so weiter. Und ähm es wurden sozusagen einfach Annahmen oder vielleicht ist bin mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so ganz sicher, ob das äh Testdatum war, glaube ich, äh schon noch ein Kriterium, aber
letzten Endes ist ja entscheidend Symptombeginn lässt
eher darauf schließen, wann eine tatsächliche Infektion stattgefunden hat und dann lässt es sich eben auch entsprechend darauf schließen, an welchem Tag ein höheres Infektionsrisiko vorlag. Und.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen das Ziel, diesen transmissionriss Parameter besser einzustellen.
Ist doch eh viel zu niedrig. Also sorry, die also.
Und er wurde auch und die Parameter wurden auch erhöht. Also das ist sozusagen eine doppelte Maßnahme. Also es wurde sozusagen alles auch noch einen Tag früher geschoben und ein bisschen höher gemacht. Also die Kurve ist ein bisschen äh größer geworden. Äh
Plus man kann jetzt über diese Symptombefragung unter Umständen noch genauer lokalisieren, an welchem Tag man den ausrichten muss. Also es ist schon eine Anpassung.
Gut und dann gibt es jetzt auch noch die, die internationale ähm äh die Internationalität, die, wie ihr ja hier auch schon äh besprochen hatten, die dann jetzt ausgerollt wurde. Ich persönlich ähm bin da nicht,
also ich denke, also was was notwendig ist,
habe ich ja auch gesagt, ne, das feature der Zusammenkunft, habe ich auch nochmal einen Blogpost zugeschrieben, wurde auch äh tatsächlich ähm einigermaßen gut wahrgenommen. Ja, wurde, musste ich nochmal ein paar Radiointerviews zu geben. Ähm.
Aber ich denke.
Also ja, ich ich bleibe dabei, dass sich das Ding grade nicht in die richtige Richtung entwickelt, ja? Und diese Internationalität kommt natürlich auch wirklich pünktlich,
pünktlich zum nächsten Lockdown, ja? Zum Ende der Ferien. Das ist dann doch jetzt nix, worüber man äh unbedingt jubeln kann, ne.
Ja gut, ich meine, man kann jubeln, muss man ja vielleicht nicht gleich,
Es ist da, ne? Und äh wie's ausgerollt wird, zeigt auch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die Problematik. Äh derzeit sind ja nur,
Irland, Deutschland und Italien mit dabei,
und äh es ist absehbar, dass diese Zahl der Länder äh schnell steigt, aber es bedeutet ja auch, die müssen ihre Apps angepasst haben, die müssen quasi diese neue ähm diese neuen Reisestatus äh Parameter
und die müssen voneinander wissen, wo die Server sind, also die sind sozusagen,
auch aufeinander abgestimmt, weil wenn ich jetzt halt wirklich mal äh in Irland äh war ein paar Tage, merkt sich das jetzt mein Telefon und dann wird eben für diese Tage auch der irische Server nach Kies gefragt. Das ist so quasi die Änderung. Haben wir schon haben wir schon erklärt.
Der Punkt ist tatsächlich, weißt du, ich meine, man muss ja auch immer gucken, weißt du, auf welchem Niveau wir darüber sprechen.
Und auf welchem Niveau die Öffentlichkeit darüber spricht. Ich habe gestern noch einen Artikel gelesen bei der Sendungsvorbereitung, wo jemand sich beklagt, dass die deutsche Corona-App immer noch nicht in Frankreich funktioniert.
Wo du dann denkst so, okay, also.
Also man kann der deutschen Telekom und SAP viel zu Last legen, aber nicht, ob die Franzosen da jetzt mitmachen oder nicht, ne.
Ähm anderes Thema, was was auch weiterhin hier eine Rolle spielt,
die Übersetzung habe ich auch äh gestern nochmal äh dazu gelernt, wo es natürlich jetzt noch so äh Interessentinnen gibt, wie zum Beispiel,
Was ist denn mit Arabisch und Russischen Übersetzungen, ne? Und dass man dann irgendwie, dann kriegst du vom äh Gesundheitsministerium äh offenbar auf Anfrage zurück. Ja, das wäre ja so kompliziert.
Ähm oder es wäre technisch viel komplizierter und viel teurer das Ding, irgendwie in diese Sprachenübersetze zu lassen, wegen ähm äh wegen äh von rechts nach links geschrieben.
Wo du dir denkst, so wollt ihr, wollt ihr Witze machen? Ihr habt irgendwie zwanzig Millionen für diese App bekommen?
Und äh jetzt könnt ihr die die App mit dem einfachsten User Interface im ganzen App Store nach einer Taschenlampen App,
ja? Äh könnt ihr könnt ihr nicht mal eben übersetzen.
Also langsam äh komme ich mir dann da doch ähm nicht mehr ganz ernst genommen vor.
Albert, ich meine, das das übernimmt das Betriebssystem für einen sowieso äh automatisch, wenn das ein Arabisch ist, dann geht das halt auch alles von von rechts nach links, ist halt da.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass du ähm also dass da dass die äh ein paar Grafiken neu malen müssen, das ist richtig. Äh ich gehe davon aus, dass sie ähm.
Eventuell zum Beispiel irgendwelchen Liegelies, ne, der da sich noch drin verbirgt, natürlich in die andere Sprache übersetzen müssen und korrekt,
Also das ist nicht so
du wirst mal einfach dein, dein, dein Gitterprojekt in in und hast dann auf einmal eine arabische App, ne? Da ist schon das ist schon mit einigem Aufwand verbunden und das kann auch mal einen Monat dauern, ne? Und das kann auch mal ein paar tausend Euro kosten
Ne, das will ich alles gar nicht in in Frage stellen, aber wenn das als Problem identifiziert wird und und überhaupt, nee, als Problem akzeptiert wird,
in einer, in einer App, die mehrere Millionen gekostet hat, dann äh läuft irgendwas schief. Das kannst du so nicht machen. Da kann man ja auch irgendwie so fantastische Preise raus, das ist jetzt die türkische Übersetzung, hätte achtzigtausend Euro gekostet, ne.
Da machen andere Leute eine ganze App mit. In in zwanzig Sprachen.
Ja, aber die arbeiten auch nicht bei SAP.
Ja, die verdienen dann wenigstens noch Geld damit.
Kleiner Hinweis noch auf äh meine aktuelle UKW äh Folge, wo ich mich mit dem Henning Thema mal über diese ganzen Fragen von wo könnte diese ganze Corona-Warn-App äh sich noch verbessern lassen? Äh ausführlich besprochen haben, so.
Dieser Typ von der SPD, der immer so tut, als wenn ich von der SPD, ne.
Genau.
Alles klar. Dann haben wir ähm noch einen Jobangebot ähm von Noib,
Ähm Max Sims hat mich da äh gebeten, da doch mal drauf aufmerksam zu machen. Sucht einen fullsteck Web Developer With Focus On Legal. Also ähm.
Freund und Backentwicklungen für deren webbasierten Systeme, zum Beispiel äh also Gruppenaktionsapps und Legal Systems, ja? Also ähm.
Dass du dein, die wollen in offenbar, ne, was man jetzt so aus der Sache heraus äh liest eben, der Öffentlichkeit zugängliche Tools bauen, die zum Beispiel dir helfen, deine GDPA Rechte einzufordern
ne? Oder äh automatisch äh zu zu detektieren, ob da irgendwas ähm
Äh wie wie es irgendwie in bestimmten Weboberflächen aussieht, ne, also wer äh ob da irgendwas eingebunden ist, ne? Wir erinnern uns, dass äh äh
äh kurz nach diesem Urteil, wo jetzt die Standardvertragsklauseln und dass der Privacy Shield äh wieder gestürzt sind, dann auch direkt mal ähm
ein paar ähm.
Beschwerden rausgegeben haben und so weiter. Also äh Fullsteak Developer Web oder Developerin auf Deutsch, äh wird gesucht,
Erfahrungen mit PRP, Softwareanalyse und so weiter, Privacy, Fokus sollte schon dabei sein und.
Gesucht wird für Wien, Österreich, aber teilweise remote ist auch möglich,
und man kann das zum Beispiel auch mit Freelance kombinieren. Also sie wollen dich nicht unbedingt exklusiv haben. Ja.
Das äh sei hiermit empfohlen. Der äh der äh die Ausschreibung, die Stellenausschreibung finden wir in den,
findet ihr in den.
Ja, das äh bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung. War ja gar nicht so kurz.
Gar nicht so kurz, aber auch nicht so lang, wie ich dachte, nachdem wir, nachdem wir eine halbe Stunde Bilderbesprechung gemacht haben.
Für jeden was dabei.
Trotzdem kompakt und unterhaltsam, das ist Lokbuchnetzpolitik. Da ist äh viel zu holen und das.
Schlechte Nachrichten, ja? Alle mit Realitätsbezug.
Mhm. Aber ohne Werbung des BND, ne? Also der.
Wir machen's eh ohne Werbung, ja? Und ohne äh und ohne allzu viel ähm,
Wir danken an dieser Stelle. Also ich danke äh Christin, Michael, Christian.
Und einer unbekannten Person ähm und wie immer, wenn ihr euren, wenn ihr eure Namen hier vermisst in dieser Dankesliste, äh dann äh freue ich mich über einen kurzen Hinweis.
So vermissen nach zwei, drei Wochen ungefähr.
Alright. Dann verabschieden wir euch äh eine spannende Woche und äh hoffen wir mal alle, dass ihr noch äh Freiräume genießen dürft.
Stimmt, wir haben wir haben kaum über diese steigenden Zahlen hier gesprochen, ne?
Ich habe was sollen wir an dieser Stelle denn auch dazu sagen? Also ich äh werde mich gleich bei UKW nochmal sehen, ja äh ausführlich darüber unterhalten
die Zahlen steigen und äh es äh ist auch schon Zahlen sind auch gerade dabei mir wieder meine Zeitpläne zu ruinieren. Genauso wie März,
und äh ist alles nicht so schön. Von daher kann man nur sagen, haltet euch ein bisschen äh zurück, seid einfach ein bisschen zurückhaltender. Jetzt haben wir noch die Möglichkeit
hier was zu einzuschränken, auch wenn's schon fast nicht mehr danach aussieht.
Ich sitze hier den ganzen Tag in meiner Selbstisolation.
Ja, ich auch. Wo ist es?
Ja. Nee, du bist heute in die Metaebene gegangen. Ach so, du gehst da gar nicht mehr raus.
Gut. Gefangene in der Metaebene seit sechs Monaten. Ja, kannst du mal sehen.
Deswegen riecht das da so ein bisschen komisch. Alles klar.
Bis bald, Leute. Tschüss.
Haltet die Ohren steif. Ciao ciao.
Facebook.
Also.
No surprise ergänzt.
Sommer.
Ist Lüdepress.
Freedom of Speech is not, Freedom of Rage.
Second.
Sylt.
Vor.
Und.
Ist.
Pfiff.
Yes.
In.